oh that
yeah okay
so that was syntax and now comes
semantics this is lecture number six and
U semantics here is the is the big
region in the
middle that uh touches the local
variables all the equivalence table and
uh and gets a next token here and there
from syntax
routines um and then uh uh I divided
part of it here into the part of uh Tech
82 that's doing math uh well this is all
really semantics and the math was just
one big chunk of it I'm not going to
talk uh anymore about math in this hour
except saying it's more of the same as
what we're going to be doing so the
things that we're going to be talking
about now is part of this is part of TCH
thematics and and uh uh with math it's
just just U um similar and and there you
can find it in the code where there's
special data structures for math um so
in the dynamic memory we not only have H
list node V list node and so on but we
have different kinds of things called no
ads no oad that uh are used for the
things that can occur there like
fractions and square roots overline um
binary relations and so on new data
stres for math um and special part of
the semantic routines that set up those
data structures print them out and and
change them into the kind of data
structures that the rest of tech knows
about um the big big routine in math is
called mless to H list this converts an
M list masth type list into an hlist a
horizontal type list and then the arot
tech knows what to do with h list so
those are those are somehow sort of
self-contained into a world on
themselves so I call it math on here and
it represents about 40% of the code for
semantics in Tech we'll talk about the
other 60% in this hour so that you get
and then those you want to look at the
others uh should be able to follow that
in the same in the same
way to start out uh the semantics I
suppose we ought to talk about the uh um
the big switch of tech this is the or
the so-called chief executive the
program that takes over when Tech is is
running um mentioned that Tech consists
of lots of procedures and then there's a
little driver program at the end that
starts the procedures going well the
thing that that it starts going is
called main control and this is uh where
where are we here um chief executive
sections 9006 on page
318 th this is the Hub of the web this
is where everything um comes together
when I was writing main control I had uh
to get a new desk to work on uh with the
whole Tech program spread out all over
the desk because I had to be picking up
you know uh remembering what all the sub
routines do um and all the naming
conventions that I had used there
because I and I had my finger in several
places always at once uh uh because this
is referring to the rest of the program
and drive and picks up the other things
uh starts them going at one um uh this
uh uh uh part of the program also has
been um made a little bit more
complicated to read because it's inner
loop stuff when you when you're going
through a paragraph and uh trying to to
uh set text this is the uh the the high
priority for for the money of the thing
so um uh
the main control procedure consists of
um has been tuned in order to to go fast
on on the on the text so main control
looks something like this big
switch um is
um uh says get NC
token and then res
switch is um another label where we
could come back back to in case we
didn't like the token we got and we want
to try again without getting another one
or we want to use it again in some other
slight disguise and here there's a bunch
of little code for uh pause for
interrupt you can interrupt at this
point and uh you can also um uh it'll
tracing commands will print out the
command that it got here so when we were
running yesterday and it said here is
where I got a blank space Here's Where
the letter B came through that was at
this point reswitched but um uh except
for this diagn itic information then
it's a big case and it's case abs of
mode plus Cur
command of and then we have a bunch of
things that will be like V mode
plus
um uh plus Skip and this would be for uh
plus v skip say for a v skip that occurs
in vertical mode um and uh H mode plus h
skip might be another another case
um uh so here's a another type where I
where I split into many many cases by uh
adding together um the current command
to to to something V mode has been set
up and H mode they've been set up to be
spaced apart so that these will uh these
will all give us unique unique division
into cases okay now the now I suppose
there's also an M mode plus h skip CU H
skip is allowed in that mode and then in
most of these cases there will be a
um uh there will just be a procedure
call here like uh I don't know what it
but do glue or something it won't be
called that but but it will be a
there'll be a procedure call here and
it's called an action
procedure then in your in your listing
there will be another module Say it'll
there'll be called declare action
procedures uh needed in main module in
in main control and and another one of
the action procedures will be procedure
do
glue and then it'll do it'll actually do
the it'll actually do the uh uh the
thing that uh that you want it to
do um uh for these three cases uh the
reason I separate this out is because a
lot of people have to use Pascal
compilers that um put restrictions on
how big a a procedure can be um uh and U
and so main control procedure if I had
all of these if I had all these
semantics inside the main control
procedure it would way exceed these uh
this limit um especially on IBM machines
which wants everything to fit uh into a
small area that they can use only two
base registers for so so the the um um
so main control consists mostly of this
case statement and calls on on
procedures uh The Only Exception is
those cases that are really in the
mainstream for the for the inner loop
something like for example H mode plus
letter H mode plus letter H mode plus
other
Char uh this is what you find in the
middle
of in the middle of text and this is
handled right um in the main control
procedure
itself
uh and the and with the things that will
look for ligatures and do those
things
um there are a few other things like
spaces between Words which were
considered important enough to put most
of the most of their code the the common
code for space between words also in
main control procedure now the uh um the
Cur command is one of these command
codes that section 2011 lists all those
command codes section 2011 and the next
one and we take a look at those
codes um uh to we we looked yesterday at
the first at page 2011 we looked at the
first 16 codes but on page 202 it shows
the next codes and and this extends way
so uh we got um uh code like charam
that's for the
backc math charam Mark input x-ray is uh
the internal code name for uh show
instructions and make box H move all of
these all of these um are command codes
for different things Tech has to do all
the way goes to the next page now on the
next page uh by the way can we have the
house lights on a little more so that
people can
read um people yeah is that better okay
can you see it enough in the first row
because you get some of light from this
guy okay thanks uh now the um uh the the
codes above uh Max non- prefixed
command uh uh which is a which changes
from day to day as Tech gets larger or
smaller uh but it's now equal to 69 uh
these codes up 70 and and up to 91 here
are all um are all things that somebody
might want to say is global or uh or so
on maybe outer or deaf or something but
you have these commands that that will
take a prefix and they're independent of
the mode
if you really had to cut down Main
control further um and and and uh you
had too many cases to handle you could
rewrite it so that res switch would
check if KK command is bigger than Max
non- prefix command then uh then do a
prefixed command uh else do do a case
statement like this then you could re
then you could cut down the definition
of h mode H mode is now I think 91 you
could cut it down to 70
uh so that you so that these branches
cuz cuz all the all these codes 70 up to
91 are really done this you do the same
thing for them independent of the mode
and and all of them really just call the
one procedure called prefixed
command so um uh I I didn't do that now
because why should I add something to
the inner loop if I some code to make a
if test in the in Loop if it's not
necessary but you could cut down the
size of main control by 3 * 20 uh case
in that case statement uh since they all
go to the same place and they're all
consecutive uh well three consecutive
regions uh of the uh of the cases do
that um now the codes above Max command
are the ones that get NC token will will
uh wipe out uh undefined control
sequence uh will not get through nor
will marks Top Mark bottom Mark call
Long call outer call Long outer call U
these last won't even occur through the
scanner these appear in the EQ EQ table
but they're only used to tell for for
purposes of uh of uh when we are
updating the data structure to tell
whether we need to update reference
counts or not um so so these last things
don't have to do with with uh coming
through get next at all but these six
here are taken care of by get NC
token so that's what the CK command will
be one of these codes now suppose you
wanted to you uh wanted to to figure out
how Tech does a certain a certain thing
like let's try to figure out uh uh
suppose you didn't happen to know that
x-ray was the internal code of Showbox
but you wanted to see well how how the
heck does Tech do a Showbox okay well
the answer is you look in the index
under Showbox primitive and for every
primitive of tech there are 242 or three
of these uh they're listed in that same
kind of a fashion like Showbox primitive
here is on page
um and it's alphabetized under sh not
under
backslash there are three or four
Primitives that are only one character
long and those are indexed under Single
Character Primitives right here on that
same page fortunately a shach uh there
are four of them and uh but otherwise
The Primitives have are are made out of
letters and there and uh um so so
that'll refer you to where um where the
Primitive was actually loaded into the
hash table every primitive is put into
Tech uh hash table by the initech
program and this particular one was done
in module 1159 so if we turn to
1159 we will
see um of course now
we're we're we're paging around in this
code without looking at the environment
too much but uh um here we'll see a call
on primitive procedure Showbox now the
this this procedure primitive is what's
used to enter all The Primitives so I
call it 242 times um and there's a
module 218 says put each of text
Primitives into the hash table and this
is one of the one of the thing things
that belongs with that module because of
the plus here um and uh so all these and
and uh that module 218 would refer you
to all the calline Primitive if you
really wanted a list of all the
Primitives now uh show Showbox then is
put in with and and then here's the
command and the CH the the the modifier
to the command so the command code for
Showbox is X-ray and the character or
modifi Showbox code so that if somebody
writes Showbox what comes through text
scanner is C command will be X-ray and
CER will be Showbox code which we've
defined here to be
one U right after putting something in
primitive I also decl have a have a case
of the print command and Char uh
procedure there's a procedure that we
have to use when we're tracing commands
that's going to con that's going to be
used in in in res switch here uh to
print the thing out in symbolic form
it's not going to say you're doing
command number 12 uh C Char is one it's
going to want to say Showbox and so um
in so x-ray uh in inside of that
procedure is going to just is going to
look at the uh the CH code and it's
going and it's going to find Showbox
code there so it'll print Showbox with
an escape character in front of it and
so then then you you'll see what um what
came through in this uh print command
and CH procedure it's supposed to be
robust it's supposed to be able to
handle cases that can't ever really be
there there's no way for a tech user to
to put to to get command x-ray
associated with any code other than
these here Tech user can never uh enter
uh the uh uh something in the hash table
whose command is x-ray
um only the Primitive procedure is
allowed to do this by by any Tech but
but you guys could do this by by
changing the web listing doing something
you know you you can get anything into
uh into that eqb especially if you make
a mistake so uh so this print command
and chair procedure uh has to never give
an error message U um specifically by
calling error it it actually can be used
in inside of other routines which we
wouldn't want to to to lead to an error
message but they has to do something in
all cases well it's just going to say
show in all those other cases sometimes
if I think there's really a chance that
somebody would have would want to know
that it was a bad one I I would have I
would have Rewritten this if I felt U
really uh needed it and I would have
show code printing show in the other
cases would say unknown x-ray or
something like that but um uh I I want
to make sure that that that you know
that this the procedure does always have
a do something in every case uh that
doesn't that doesn't abort your
job um so then Showbox comes through as
x-ray well what about um um uh now how
does that get acted on well it's um we
could Now find that by looking in the
index under x-ray to see where where
x-ray is used but that would refers us
right back to the previous page so save
us to save time we look here and we say
uh cases of main control that don't
depend on most mode one of them is going
to be any mode X-ray and it's going to
call a procedure called show whatever so
show whatever is one of these action
procedures I'm talking about it and and
most of the semantics are done by uh
action procedures like that and here it
is in uh next page there on module
1161 uh declare action procedures for
use by main control one of the things is
procedure show whatever and this is U it
looks at the Cure and if it's Showbox
code then it gets us to module 1164 show
the current contents of a box okay well
turn to page
1164 uh show the current contents of a
box scan an 8bit
integer um that's a special routine that
calls scan integer and makes and if it's
not between 0 and 255 it gives you an
error message saying that it should have
been between 0 and 255 and that is
changing it to zero on you uh then we
print a new line
and this greater than sign in box and we
print integer curve Val scan 8bit
integer reduce puts its answer in curv
val um it's one of the reasons I wanted
to use a global for this because because
all the time I'm scanning something and
I don't want to have to have a new local
every time for the dumb thing um and and
actually specifically assign it um but I
got to be careful of course that I don't
it doesn't get wiped out by something
else in the in the meantime and that's
the danger the well-known dangers of
global variables are that uh somebody
else if if if everybody uses curve Val
like if print new line would use curve
Val I'd certainly be in trouble so uh
you do this only when you know that your
use of the thing is going to be near the
near the time it was actually stored in
the global variable otherwise you're in
trouble and also I couldn't do this well
if I if I made main control recursive uh
so that people would incorporate a whole
Tech job inside of another one uh then I
would have to have curve Val be local to
main
control all right now print
Char uh equal sign so box whatever is
going to be equal to and then um we have
two cases but it's notice it refers to
box of curl this is um a a macro uh that
refers to a position in eqb the current
value of of that box um and it's a
pointer to the box it's either an H list
node or V list node if the box is there
but if it's null that means that the Box
there's no box there and u tech calls
that absent um otherwise we use the
Showbox routine that displays all these
boxes out in various lines using the uh
um the Showbox depth and Showbox breadth
parameters to to cut off uh explain how
much is actually being shown then we
give an ER then we give an error message
okay that's not really an error in The
Help message that goes with that was
described on the previous page there it
says we saw it yesterday this isn't an
error message I'm just showing something
that's the whole thing that's a
semantics for
Showbox um and it's typical of a simple
case of semantics and there are 91 * 3
branches to this uh thing so about 273
cases um uh you switch into from this
res switch procedure and one by one you
check those off and and uh make sure
that that that Tech is doing the right
thing on
it
okay uh now you want to add something to
Tech um the extensions uh usually come
through a um uh a single place let me
see if I can find the for extensions
detect we talk about that a second
module 2 129 right near the end is where
extensions are
discussed and um
and uh it's worth uh reading that just
to get a feeling for what you have to
suppose you added a new feature to Tech
how many different parts of tech would
actually be changed to to accommodate
that feature well you got to put a new
primitive in the uh hash table you got
to um uh maybe uh put a new kind of
what's it node uh type into your data
structure um I see Lyall sitting here
near the front row he's uh put in the
feature at Xerox that prints in color uh
so he knows uh what you know what goes
on in these things but there's various
places where you have to where where
Tech would actually uh get extended and
we and I tried to make most of those all
uh be possible to put them into this one
place extensions and uh provide hooks
into the main program that uh so that it
you don't have to um affect the rest of
it
oh I got a beep from something warning
five minutes to automatic log out let me
see
okay
yeah I don't know if I'll use the
computer but I want it to make be logged
in just in case excuse me so um so these
hooks are shown um in the in the in the
sections there following
1209 and um most of the case though we
won't have to uh we won't have to add a
new command code if we're lucky we won't
have to add anything to main control
because of what's uh because there's one
the command code is called extension and
it just has a a chur part that says what
kind of extension you have so if
possible when you make an extension to
Tech use extension as your command code
and just give another CH field and then
the action procedure that you get is um
let me see right there
1216 module 1216 is um any mode
extension do extension and calls the
action procedure in 1217 do
extension uh which just is a case
statement that implements the different
extensions and gives confusion if it's
an extension it doesn't know about
confusion is um the uh is an interesting
error message it it's a uh it this is
where Tech types out this can't
happen um but actually it doesn't type
out this can't happen all the time it
it's remembered whether there's been an
error at least one error before if this
is the first error that Tech has seen
then it says this can't happen but if
something but if the user has really has
screwed up before it says um uh uh
something else uh let's take a look at
confusion just to see what so you get
the idea what that is cuz confusion is
used to for internal consistency checks
in Tech um confusion is defined
in you guys are fat what
90 okay module number 90 page 32 of
Confusion And so there's a Boolean
Global Boolean variable called spotless
and that is uh set ordinarily to True
until you've got your first error so if
it's spotless it says this can't happen
then it gives the indication of what
can't happen uh it would say X1 in that
case and um and then it gives a help
message U uh there uh then
that help message by the way will show
up on your on on um on your
file uh let's see wait a
minute because the succumb procedure
this the the succumb procedure is is uh
guaranteed to uh to to cause a fatal
error this is where it dies uh but on
the other case it says I can't go on
meeting you like this and then it uh uh
and then so you stop but a different
help message okay
so so that's what confusion prints on
okay now back to
extensions I'm glad that some of you are
chuckling you know I worked on this a
little
bit okay now so the so the extensions um
uh occur
in the the hooks are are
indicated uh let's see in
um uh
like on page on module 1225 page
400 um you'll see the um uh that I've
made a Whatsit node have four subtypes
for the four things that I'm treating as
extensions in Tech uh I'm considering op
open send close and exent as if they
were extensions uh to provide a example
paradigms of what what you do for
extensions um and so 12:25 says in the
case sub type gives four cases otherwise
it now this is for displaying of what's
it node so we always we don't want to
give an error message and so if we don't
know what what is we just print out
what's it and don't don't say confusion
in that case um but if we're copying a
node we're copying a what's it node
that's one of the things we have to do
so module 1226 is um is a uh something
that you know belongs in section 200 um
and and uh all of these hooks from the
rest of the program have been uh filled
in here in the extension section and you
could get you have you certainly have to
provide confusion message there if
you're trying to copy a whats it node
you don't know how many words to copy so
you're in trouble the whats it nodes are
are not of a given known size open node
size is bigger than a send node size in
this particular example and the closed
node size is is uh uh two words would
turns out to be equal for the send node
size but it's a coincidence um there's a
place where you have to return uh
recycling nodes to the data structure
that's uh used in section 196 so 1227 is
the code for wipe out a what's it node
and go to done and so that so you have
to if you extend uh Tech in introducing
a new kind of what it then uh you must
uh also uh be able to create print out
and and uh free those nodes and that's
what these last three sections were
about then there's a bunch of of simple
things that didn't affect Tech at all in
the case of send open and close but they
might otherwise so we still have the
hooks so 1228 1229 1230
1231 all of these
um um let's see I think it would be good
for the videotape people to show this to
show my finger pointing even though the
people in the audience can't see my
finger too well so um uh on the uh on
these cases the modules are trivial
um like it says incorporate a what's it
note into an hbox and the um uh the code
for that is do nothing do nothing if you
that's a macro in web that expands into
nothing that's an empty statement um let
D be the width of the what's it node p d
is set to zero that's so all of these
are trivial things but you have to um uh
if you add a what's it where you want to
do something then you'd have to check on
the what's it nodes type and see that
you were doing the right
thing okay so uh this gives an idea as
to what parts of tech uh would be
affected if you add something new to the
language whenever you add something new
to Tech you realize that you're making
it impossible for your programs to run
at somebody else's installation and uh
you have to and I I would strongly
recommend that everybody keep a a uh
vanilla version of tech around for those
people who want to write programs for us
other users uh does not let it grow to
the point where where uh we can't share
uh where we can't share anymore a lot of
effort has been put into this program to
make it possible to to to be used in um
in uh uh thousands of computer centers
around the world uh and we can we can do
that if we keep our our extensions uh in
uh control so that we we that you'll
also be able to have a change file that
doesn't include all of your extensions
somebody says I want to write something
that I know is going to work at somebody
else's machine then uh you should you
should have one there you should have
you should have a version of tech that
that uh does that for him okay now um
I'd like to follow one more thing
through the semantics uh to finish so
that we can get an idea of the rest of
the semantics and so let's try um well
unless anybody has a better example I I
I thought i' try uh fing through the an
hbox to something and then just make the
list uh rather trivial but let's let's
let's make a small hbox and see what
what it
does so suppose I want to um say hbox to
um
um 100
points of the letter A
okay that shouldn't be a hard thing but
it'll actually take us in a little
Adventure through a lot of different
parts of
tech okay now
um first place we we have to well let's
think about what what what we imagine
would be going on after you have the
after you see hbox Tech has to look
ahead and see if it if you specify
something like to 100 point or expand by
100 points or just uh if if it's just
hbox with nothing after it
um uh there there are two cases of hbox
that you can see that uh one is where
you give a u a particular size and then
the glue will have to be set so that you
reach that size somehow we don't have
any glue in here um it's too bad maybe
I'll put a space after that and uh
that'll and well if there was no glue um
we have we we might as well see what
happens if there is no blue in the Box
okay um anyway one case is that we
specify a final size 100 points exactly
the other case is that we expand by a
given amount where this could be expand
100 points and that would say take your
natural size and make it 100 points more
um the special time when you write just
hbox and left brace that's expand by
zero
point so you have these kinds of things
that can occur um spef the specification
of what kind of an hbox we have there's
two cases the expanding and the exact
and exactly then
um uh hbox can be used in different
context that it can be preceded by a lot
of different things um for example it
could have been preceded by
lower lower two points and that means
you know move it down too if it's in an
H list uh it could have been preceded by
um shipout
uh which says uh how it goes we it could
have been preceded by
leaders which says this box is going to
represent uh uh the replicating part in
leaders and going to be that's going to
be followed by Glue so there there's
various contexts by
which um this in which this hbox could
have appeared and we want to uh we have
to somehow remember then as we're as
we're building up the h box we're going
to have to remember what we're going to
do with it after we finished with the
Box um so where does Tech remember that
well
um uh the answer is on the save stack we
also remember stuff like that yesterday
I told you that the save stack was used
for saving and restoring equivalents um
and that it had this kind of we put fix
up instructions on the save stack and
then we had boundary words on the save
stack too
well just um just uh after those
boundary words or before the boundary
words whatever you you want to call it
uh there's room for there's it's a nice
place to put stuff before you get to the
new to the fix-ups afterward cuz if
you're going to come back to this
boundary word it's going to be at a time
when you know uh what kind of a boundary
word it was so the boundary word
includes a code that tells you what kind
of a uh group you're in and in this case
will be in an hbox group when we finish
an hbox group we'll be ready to read
some stuff off of the top of this off
the off of the save stack that will tell
us that this hbox was being lowered
perhaps by something um or maybe it was
being put into leaders or maybe it was
there was a set box 100 equals this in
front of it um all that information will
be encoded uh on the save stack at the
end at at the end and so the save stack
contains below its boundary words
contains mysterious other information uh
and then and then fix UPS um
occurring now there's a there's a a
factoring problem involved here somehow
I I mentioned there are different things
that can come in front of it like lower
leaders I didn't mention um set box but
that's another one uh it's called save
in the present Tech but set box in Tech
um and uh you might have said Global set
box which which uh which is different
from just from a local set box and uh a
few other things can precede um Can
precede this and then all of these
operations can take any box so these
operations could Al could have could
apply to hbox to a v box to a vtop and a
few other vs split there are a few other
cases that uh that make into a box and
so all so you have um uh two things that
are that uh multiply together all the
possibilities for how to use a box and
all the possibilities for how to make a
box and uh so we so Tech wants to
represent uh all these combinations so
so um first so these these uses of a box
put something on the save stack
corresponding to the use of the box and
then uh and then they they uh and then
all the different ways to make a box put
something on the safe stack saying what
kind of box they're making and
everything is finally gloriously put
together at the end
um now let's take a look at the that's
the the general problem that had to be
solved uh when we look at the specific
case we want to keep a a little aware of
of of the environment of that case I see
if I can find out where hbox uh uh is uh
done now let's see building boxes and
list is this part uh 46 that starts on
page 326 and module
um and and uh uh but it starts getting
into
boxes uh let's see um on like module
939 tells how it's going to represent
the context of the
box and the context of the box in the
simple case that we just have an hbox in
the middle of some other list with
nothing else in front of it the context
is going to be like lower by zero
because we're just going to it's going
to be treated as a special case of lower
lowering or raising or moving left to
right where the amount of shifting is
zero so the context code for that is
going to turn out to be zero but there
will be a context code placed um on the
uh save
stack so when we when we scan hbox um it
it's going to come through the command
code for that is make box and all of
these different contexts are going to
insist that makebox command is the next
one otherwise uh there will be an error
message saying
um I expected a box specification here
or something like
that um and the
um um uh the any mode makebox comes
through on module
951 and so so module 951 the last two
lines of that any mode makebox saved
zero is set to zero begin box now saved
zero
um is an abbreviation for Save
stack of
um of save
pointer plus
Z and saved one the same thing for
sticking in a one here so this means it
goes at the top of the save stack safe
pointer minus one is where the the
information that uh that's really at the
top of the stack goes and uh zero this
this is the the first place that's
available on that stack um if any of you
looked at the code for Save stack go
it's made sure that there's always
always five or six uh places available
before it checks again to see whether
it's run out of save stack space the
test we don't have to test here whether
or not there's room on the save stack
that test has already been made that
there's always room for five or six
things
um cuz whenever it does test it's at a
point that it's guaranteed never to put
fi or six things on before the next test
but I don't want to be testing all over
the place okay so now save zero in other
words this position on Save stack is set
to zero indicating uh equivalent to a
shift amount by zero because if I had uh
okay so some of the other possibilities
for getting the context code are
described in other mind I don't want to
go into that so um so we got zero in
that position then we call begin box the
begin box sube and U unfortunately I was
not able to uh write the begin box sube
next because it
calls
nbox a box end sub routine um and I had
to declare box ends first I had uh the
reason is that uh when I begin a box I
don't know I um all I've seen so far is
a makebox I don't know that I'm making
an hbox this might be some simple thing
like instead of hbox it might have just
said box
20 in which case I would I would be able
to finish the box right away something
like hbox I'm going to have to wait and
scan this whole thing which might be
arbitrarily long before I finish the box
but I might finish it very simply so I
call begin box now begin box is module
958 and uh that's what then is going to
look at see what kind of makebox we're
supposed to make and in this case we
have
um
other cases initiate the construction of
hbox or vbx because let me see where did
I where's my call on primitive for hbox
it must be around here
somewhere the hbox
Primitive is yeah bottom of page 330
hbox primitive for hbox is right here
and it um and and it was it's command
code is matebox it's Char code is vtop
code Plus H mode so so uh that's where
we are here um uh hbox gets a vtop code
plus h mode and that's so the H mode is
going to tell us what mode to go in when
we when we're uh when we reach this uh
point vbox would look very similar but
it would have V mode in there instead so
so as far as Tech knows it's it's uh
it's got the command code of makebox and
then it's ch code is is going to be vtop
code Plus either V mode or H mode or or
zero
and these are the three cases that we're
coming into in module now this is 962 so
module 962 here is where we
oops on 962 here's where we we uh make
in restricted horizontal mode or
internal vertical mode in order to make
a box and so the first thing is we stuff
away
Kar uh minus vtop code into a local
variable K the um uh the value of K will
be zero for vtop or otherwise it'll be V
mode for vbx or H mode for
hbox we increase the save pointer that
means then that we have now officially
put this guy on the save
stack um in order to make room for the
next thing we call Scan spec sub routine
the scan spec sub routine is what scans
this part of the
input expand or two followed by 100
points and it puts two things on the
save stack uh one of them is either zero
or one uh telling whether it's two or
expand and the other one is the
dimension 100
Point um I guess there's no point in
going to look at the scan spec
subroutine but it just calls scan
keyword and then it puts those two
things on the stack
um and uh I believe it also increases
the save pointer by two so that uh we
now have put three things onto the deck
telling us the context of this box as
well as the final dimensions of the
box now now we uh uh still have K which
tells us what uh was going on although
cure has changed many times because the
scan spec procedure is called get next
of course k equals H mode then we call
new save level hbox group so the save
pointer not the save stack is not going
to get a boundary word for an hbox
group um and uh then we're ready to know
when the right race comes along that
we're in an hbox group and so the thing
to do is to uh uh to to to uh package up
our hbox that's we'll see that in a
minute but we put on the save stack then
a boundary word that um that refers us
to an hbox group and our current group
uh the current type of thing we're in is
going to be hbox otherwise for V vbox
and vtop is similar things go then we
say push nest and here's something I uh
want to know about in Tech U um it
has uh it has a stack for all the
semantic activities for for various um
kinds of lists and uh and this has State
information analogous to the input State
remember when we were talking about
syntax last hour the syntax would have a
state and lo and limit and there were a
few other things we didn't uh we didn't
get into but like the name of the file
you're reading is part of your state um
the uh semantics also have these have a
have a stack of of these things and uh
one of the things is the mode that
you're in that's that's a current part
of your semantic State and then you have
um um the head the head and tail of the
list that you're building so if you're
in horizontal mode for example you're
building a horizontal list head points
to the beginning of that horizontal list
tail points to the end of that
horizontal
list um there's a the space factor is
another part of the uh of your mode of
your of your uh State as far as
semantics is concerned for building
horizontal
lists so um we would uh so when we say
push Nest this says um all of State
variables that go into semantics save
them away in your nest stack for
semantics and so that they'll pop up
again later when we're done with this
but but they all get saved um and so
we're pushing some things on the save
stack and some things in the nest stack
well uh turn out to be convenient to do
that um then we set mode to minus K now
K is either H mode or V mode so it's and
uh the mode the value of of your current
mode is six possibilities there's
vertical
mode and V mode and minus V mode uh
minus V mode is internal vertical mode
and plus v mode is what you have when on
the outermost level of tech building
Pages then there's H mode and minus H
mode uh minus H mode is restricted
horizontal mode that's what you have in
the middle of an hbox plus h mode is the
uh uh uh ordinary horizontal mode which
you have for building a
paragraph then there's M mode and minus
M mode plus M mode is in a displayed
math formula NM mode is in a text math
formula so those are the six modes and
that's part of you and and so when you
say push Nest that saves away your mode
and your head and tail of your current
list your space factor or pre depth or
whatever was was part of the mode there
and also uh uh presents you with a fresh
new mode a brand new mode you're new you
now got an empty list that you're
building so your head is now pointing to
um a a special location in memory that's
just going to be the head of this list
it's not really an element of a list but
it's a it's a base of of the thing and
the tail is poined to the same place so
that is representing an empty
list um and uh the mode that when I say
push Nest I stay in the same mode I was
in um uh but now I change it to minus K
which is minus H mode or minus V mode so
now I'm going to make either a v box or
an H box
and uh I have to initialize the space
factor in the case of horizontal mode so
I I set space factor to a th th000 is
the normal space factor meaning don't
don't make any correction to spacing um
if space Factor was 2,000 it would say
double your your stretch your stretch
ability in the spacing and half your
shrinkability
um and that return that then return
which which means means go to exit go
get out of the procedure for begin a box
so now uh this is a a a simple case of
post hypnotic suggestion here's where we
we now return to main control and we go
back into tech and and uh we we uh have
our fingers crossed that someday
somewhere a right brace is going to come
along and we're going to be able to
finish this hbox but we we are
fearlessly um let Tech uh uh run uh with
its head uh do whatever it wants to now
to the to this hbox and all kinds of
things can happen before we ever get
back control again those things will
presumably be uh uh our state will
presumably be pushed down on either the
save stack or the nesting stack or both
um whenever uh something even more
complicated comes along but someday
we're going to get back and a right
brace is going to come along and take us
out well what does come along in this
case um wait a minute where did I say
scan left brace
oh the scan spec sub routine actually
scanned away the left brace
too um why not because one of the things
it could have been was hbox left brace
and why should we have to back up so it
takes away the left brace
too scan spec sube is only used in two
places here and after H
Aline um V Center I guess another case
okay now now so so we've we've we've
pushed our previous mode into the nest
and um uh we're in a fresh mode with an
empty list next thing comes through the
scanner is H mode plus uh a letter
letter
a um okay do we see do we have time I
guess we we have time to do a little bit
of this um but I'll I won't go through
all the details we certainly will have
to check now for the character following
a to see if it's part of a ligature and
whether kerning is needed and things
like that well I'm not going to go
through all that code
but H mode plus letter is uh the case
recognized in module 9007 and it tells
us to go to main Loop and um main Loop
is
um in um
where main Loop is in that same module
9007 and it says a pen okay here we go
main Loop is a pen character curer and
the following characters if any to the
current H list in the current font go to
Res switch when a non character has been
fetched
910 so 910 is all that action and uh
this is this is inner loop so we're
trying to be fast here f is set to curve
font this is the internal code of the
current font if it's undefined font then
we then we're not in a loop anymore and
we give uh we we call a procedure for
missing font and go back to Big switch
do nothing but uh let's suppose f is not
an unef not not undefined font then we
set C to the uh current character which
is uh ask the internal code for lower
case a
97 and we at Main Loop one which is a
label that's been explained on the
previous page it
said um main Loop one is
like um is like main Loop but F and C
are the current font and character so
that's uh I guess a correct description
of what main Loop one is now here we
have to check to see whether this is a
valid character in the font or not so he
says is is it less than font beginning
character or greater than the font
ending character cuz see because this
font might it might be valid okay but it
might not have this character in it and
uh if so then uh we have to then we have
a a CH warning procedure which um uh
which gets called and we again ignore
the character Tech will never put in its
data structure a character that doesn't
exist in the font the output routine
never has to check whether a character
is there or not that's already been done
before we ever put it in the data
structure um but so we get through this
test and Main Loop two if I bet you if I
turned back the page and and uh and gave
the camera operator more fits uh it
would just say that it was like main
Loop one except that the character also
is in the right range for the
font um so then we set a couple other
variables that are going to help us on
our ligature space Loop and um but the
gist of it all is that we're going to
finally get to Main Loop 3 which is
going to finally uh um uh put in put a
put a character into the current list in
font F what that means is the following
I've got now when I when I said push
Nest a minute ago um uh that meant that
I uh that I had a a pointer variable
called Head
which gets pushed down at at each level
uh pointing to some new word of memory
which is null uh it has a null pointer
in it and nothing nothing there this
represents an empty list and tail is
also pointing to this same place in
memory to represent the empty list now
when I get a new character a what I'm
going to do is make up a uh Char node
which is which is one of these nodes
that goes in the uh
a one-word memory and tail is going to
point to it so I'll say get a veil and
in fact I'll I'll use a special case of
get a veil that's uh uh that doesn't
call a sub routine unless um unless it's
a hard situ unless it's one of the hard
cases in order because I'm in the inter
Loop and I get an available onew
node and um and I'll have uh no pointer
in here but I'll make this one point to
this one tail will point to this one and
it'll say F here and C here the font and
the character will be stored in that
note f is already known to be in the
correct range for a quarter word but
this 97 code for aski I'm going to have
to add Min quarter word to it in order
to get it in there anyway I I'm going to
uh have a font and a character and then
a null pointer at the end of that if
this list got any longer let's suppose I
had a space there just to I won't go
through exact I won't go through the
code but I'll tell you what happened if
I put a space here what would happen we'
look at font at the current font F and
say what's the uh glue for that current
font and um in most cases there will be
a pointer to a glue specification for
that font if not we'll make up such a
pointer so that later on we can we can
do it in one step uh there will be a
pointer to a glue specification so then
this will point to um tail be moved to a
new word which is
glue and this is and this would be glue
which refers to the to the glue uh for
the uh current
font um there's a little packet that
says how much to stretch how much to
shrink how much to space for uh spaces
in in each font and uh even the
undefined font has one of these uh which
which are all zero but there this glue
will point to this word of glue
specification um and uh there's a
reference count in this word saying how
many people are pointing to it so that
this will disappear when there's no
there's uh no more uses of it but this
is a this glue is a very compact thing
uh this one has to specify three 32-bit
numbers uh so we don't want to we don't
want to waste that much space in Tech we
we do it we get by with that with just a
point just pointing to it um and have a
reference count in here to to so that
this will go away when when we don't
need it so uh this is a one-word node
for the character a two-word node for
the glue and and uh we built an H list
that contained two items in it when we
when we when we made this uh space we
checked the space factor that the space
Factor was 100 a th000 uh therefore we
we could use the standard glue for the
font otherwise we would have didd with
it uh a little
bit okay that's uh uh what we did then a
in a space then and a right brace comes
through and here's where some this is a
uh another big thing when Tech sees a
right brace almost anything can happen
depending on what that right brace means
and uh see where does a right brace come
through um I think it's
um oh goodness
uh I need some help on this right brace
anyway they a there's
um if I came if I went in in uh handle
right brace is the procedure so so when
a right brace comes through then then we
call handle right brace and uh um 964 is
the module
number um no
9 964 is the one that's used in 947
yeah okay 9 947 is the procedure handle
right brace here we are and uh it does
it has to deal with all the all the
things that can occur when a right brace
occurs now there's a lot of error
situations that that we want to detect
here um like an suppose somebody said
dollar sign and then he had a right
brace um before he finished his
formula um
well dollar sign is also considered to
go on the save stack with a boundary
word and so to the left and right and uh
there's also now something called group
begin which uh which will give you local
uh local variables just like left braces
do so there are things that so the right
brace might match something that isn't
that isn't a left brace we have to check
for that decide what to do we have to
decide for example in this case whether
not the guy forgot a dollar sign or
whether he put in a right brace that he
didn't want to um and uh so those cases
have to be have to be uh handled but in
this case we're lucky uh so we got a
right brace and what happens um it it uh
calls case Cur group of Cur group for us
is an hbox group so it must be in cases
of handle right brace where right brace
triggers a Delayed Action 90 64 and it
it's going to finally take us to mod
module
um um
no let's see
964 if I looked in the index under hbox
group I would find it yeah well here it
is
964 okay so hbox group says call package
of
zero and um if vbox group says end a
paragraph and package of zero so package
of zero must be the thing that U is
going to wrap this thing up into a
little neat little package and that's on
the next page
965 um and package of the parameter is
going to tell whether it's a vtp or
not it's all is the only other case um
unsave this is what goes through all all
the fix UPS on the uh on the save stack
so it goes back to the previous boundary
word anything that's been declared here
if I had any deps in here font changes
in here they all get undone by by the
unsafe procedure then I've got back to
the point where there are three words on
the save stack that are telling me what
kind of box I was supposed to make and
what the what the use of that box was
going to be so I decreased safe planter
by three more and now those three things
are saved zero saved one and saved
two here I uh check to see what kind of
mode I'm in if negative H mode means I
just finished a uh restrict
you know an hbox a restricted horizontal
mode so that's what that's what applies
so I set curve box to uh H pack of link
of head save two save one okay now H
pack is my packaging sub
rutine um talk about that in a sec link
of head well here's head the top of the
list link of head is the beginning of
the list so when I call hpack I want to
know where the list starts and I also
have these two things on the SA stack
that said it was 200 that says it was
200 points so I'm going to make it 8 100
points exactly uh and hpac is the sube
that's uh called the packager and the
and it's the main way to to to take a
list and make it into a box it's sort of
the way um hpack and vpack are the two
things in there uh the packaging sub
routines which come right after right
here
packaging page
196 554 Packaging
and uh that section is is um devoted to
creating um eight to the hpack sub te
hpac sub te entally runs through this
list figures out how big it
is um so it'll finds character you know
font F character c um and uh from that
it knows it looks up in the fun
information um and sees how wide the
character is how how high it is how deep
it is so we can compute the the depth of
this hbox it looks at the next thing
it's glue and it um uh Records how much
stretch ability there is whether or not
it's infinite and whatever um and uh
gets to the end of the list says see I'm
supposed to make it up to 100 points
makes up a uh makes up a new box node
that says the glue is stretching by a
certain Factor uh this is the height of
the box is the depth of the Box H pack
does all those nice things and returns a
pointer to the box it made the Box note
it made and uh as we saw it's that
pointer gets stuffed into curve
box okay that's we're in handle right
brace somewhere other well I got lost
and we're getting short of time but
that's on so the right brace has taken
us through that much and uh if I go if I
could find my code back again here on
boxes uh building boxes I bet you what
would happen next is that I would pop
the nest and go back to my
environment uh but wherever that
is Page
335 okay here we go yeah so curve boox
was set to um
hpack
um uh and uh and then uh we popped the
nest which means that we get by this
time we've got another pointer to this
to this list already this list is now
pointed to by by some box note or
other and um head is still pointing to
it but I but I wipe this note I recycle
it put it back into uh in into free
memory and then I call the Box end
procedure the Box end procedure is going
to take Cur boox and add it to the
current list in the in the outer mode
and uh we'll either it'll either lower
it or raise it or or put it in liters or
whatever the the context on save save
zero tells it to do so there we are we
finished an hbox now that's taken us
through a lot of the uh of the ideas of
tech and I think by by that example
you'll get a feeling for uh you know
what other things are going to um are
going to happen anything could have
happened inside this hbox of course it
could have called a vbx that could have
had a displayed format inside of the V
box and all that other stuff going on
but it's all done with uh the uh the
same same basic idea we save some things
on a on a nesting stack some things on a
save stack and we have a few vital
procedures like the hpack procedure that
uh make Transformations on the data
structure finally everything gets into
the data structure and um we're ready to
do things like break it into lines for
paragraphs and that's the that's the uh
subject of the lecture at 2:00 breaking
paragraphs into lines uh the most
interesting one that I want to
especially recommend is the one at 330
on hyphenation we should have some fun
with that if the computer is still up
because the brand new Hy Nation
algorithm in Tech and I want to show you
um how it works and do some experiments
with it uh so so this afternoon well
both of them are pretty good but the
hyphenation one will be the most fun for
me